cubrimos ya la idea de lo que es la
longitud de un vector longitud de un
vector aunque de hecho también a veces
le llamamos norma
y eso lo vimos hace ya muchos muchos
vídeos atrás y me di cuenta de que
olvide cubrir un tema muy importante
olvide cubrir un tema que de hecho este
tema será útil cuando hagamos algunos
tipos de transformaciones por ejemplo
las proyecciones que haré en el próximo
vídeo y el concepto que olvide abordar
es la de vector unitario aunque entonces
vamos a abordar el concepto de vector
unitario y el vector unitario que no es
otra cosa más que un vector que tiene
longitud o norma 1 ok esto es un vector
de norma voy a dejarlo como norma
que ya sabemos quién es la norma de un
vector 1 simplemente este es el concepto
de vector unitario entonces por ejemplo
si tomamos un vector cualquiera y que se
encuentre en r n de hecho sabemos que
pues este vector tiene n componentes 1 2
y así sucesivamente hasta un n ok y este
vector pues al querer calcular su norma
la norma o la longitud de este vector
verdad es simplemente igual a la raíz
cuadrada de la suma de los cuadrados de
cada de todas las entradas verdad
entonces sumamos los cuadrados de todas
las entradas que todos estos al cuadrado
los sumamos y finalmente sacamos la raíz
cuadrada que no es otra cosa más que una
extensión de lo que es el teorema de
pitágoras para n dimensiones verdad
cuando cuando tenemos solo dos
coordenadas pues es el teorema de
pitágoras hablando ahí entonces un
vector unitario lo que es un vector
unitario
que íbamos a remarcar un poco que es ser
un vector unitario implica que la norma
de ese vector digamos la norma de este
vector
pues es uno ok su longitud o su normal
es igual a 1 no importa en qué dimensión
estés hablando no importa si estás en r2
r3 n recién r 10 millones no importa
pero bueno la siguiente pregunta es cómo
construimos un vector unitario entonces
vamos a partir de un vector digamos que
yo tengo el vector b ok
tengo el vector b y que tiene
coordenadas b1 b2 y así sucesivamente
hasta b n este es mi vector b y queremos
encontrar un vector o un vector que
tenga la misma dirección que ve que y
que tenga la misma dirección y sentido
que b
voy a dejarlo solo la misma dirección
que ve se entiende que entendamos que es
el mismo sentido es decir si se apunta
hacia esta dirección o debe apuntar en
la misma dirección y también queremos
ver que la norma de v sea 1 aunque
entonces más o menos en dibujitos sería
algo así si yo tengo aquí que éste es b
este es b
yo quiero buscar un vector o digamos un
vector que tenga norma 1 pero que esté
en la misma dirección y sentido desde ok
entonces
qué es lo que podemos hacer lo que
podemos hacer es tomar la norma primero
de nuestro vector b si consideramos la
norma de nuestro vector b lo que podemos
hacer posteriormente a ello es definir
un nuevo vector o que sea 1 entre la
norma debe por el vector b entonces
claramente este es un vector que apunta
en la misma dirección debe y simplemente
lo estamos rescatando de alguna forma
ahora la afirmación la afirmación es que
para empezar que para que podamos hacer
esto el vector b debe ser distinto vez
de 0 verdad y eso es claro porque pues
no habrá múltiplos de un vector que sea
el 0 que nos dé norma 1 verdad cualquier
múltiplo del vector 0 es 0 pero bueno ya
que tenemos esto vamos a calcular la
norma de eeuu quien sería la norma de
nuestro vector
vamos a ver la norma de nuestro vector y
no es otra cosa más que la norma de este
vector de aquí la norma de 1 / la norma
debe por el vector b y aquí hay que
utilizar unas propiedades que conocemos
muy bien de lo que son las normas verdad
las normas simplemente si nosotros
tenemos un número aquí que multiplica a
un vector sabemos que este numerito lo
podemos sacar con un valor absoluto
verdad entonces simplemente la norma de
una constante por el vector es el valor
absoluto de esa constante por la norma
del vector en este caso sabemos que es 1
entre la norma y que la norma siempre es
positiva verdad porque es positiva
porque no puede ser 0 entonces
forzosamente tiene que ser mayor que 0
entonces no necesitamos ese valor
absoluto así que de esta forma está este
número este número que es 1 entre la
norma lo podemos sacar de esta norma más
grande y nos queda 1 entre la norma de b
que es nuestra constante c
que juegue el papel de c en este en este
ejemplo por la norma del vector y
sabemos que 1 entre 1 entre la norma por
la norma de d
pues simplemente es una verdad esto
simplemente va a ser 1 esto se cancelan
entonces como repaso si tenemos
cualquier vector y queremos encontrar un
vector que vaya en la misma dirección y
sentido que el original pero que tenga
norma 1 simplemente hay que dividirlo
entre su norma verdad hay que definir
ese vector como uno entre la norma del
vector original por el vector original
entonces vamos a hacer un ejemplo para
que quede bien claro que es lo que hemos
estado haciendo si por ejemplo nos
tomamos un vector de que sea el vector
12 menos 1 que íbamos a tomarnos este
vector quién sería la norma debe la
norma debe pues es la raíz cuadrada de 1
al cuadrado
2 al cuadrado más menos 1 al cuadrado y
esto quién es simplemente es la raíz
cuadrada de uno más cuatro más uno que
es 6 verdad entonces su norma de 6 y
vamos a reescribir un vector unitario o
como 1 entre la raíz de 6 por el vector
original que es 12 menos 1 y que ya si
nos queremos ver más extendidos pues
esto será 1 sobre la raíz de 6 2 sobre
la raíz de 6 menos 1 sobre la raíz de 6
pero bueno ahí están dos expresiones
iguales para ese vector y tenemos ya
nada más que daría a este verificar de
quedar y verificar que la norma de este
vector es 1 y ya sólo para redondear
este tema a veces a los vectores
unitarios en vez de ponerle esta
flechita se les pone un gorrito de este
estilo para denotar que es un vector
unitario
de hecho por ejemplo tenemos algunos
vectores muy clásicos como el y j y k
verdad estos vectores que aparecen
muchísimo por ejemplo en los vídeos de
cálculo vectorial o de algunos
ejercicios sobre todo de ingeniería
estos son vectores que viven en r3 y que
son unitarios de hecho estos son la base
canónica de r3 para todos los que han
estado viendo los vídeos de
transformaciones estos son equivalentes
son equivalentes a los vectores e1 e2 y
e3 que de hecho pues como son unitarios
debería ponerles gorrito verdad y esos
son la base estándar o la base canónica
en r3 pues bueno ahora que ya expusimos
esto ya podemos empezar a usar la idea
de un vector unitario en futuros vídeos